Keanu Reeves is one of the most popular
actors in the world thanks to headlining
popular franchises including the Matrix
John Wick and Bill and Ted but his
off-screen behavior has also played a
big role in helping him capture the
hearts of millions of fans throughout
his long career Reeves has developed a
reputation for humbleness charitable
gestures and genuine acts of kindness
those endearing characteristics have
earned him a reputation as one of the
nicest human beings working in the film
industry today many of reasons
collaborators over the years have
publicly recounted how much they enjoy
working with him frequently confirming
his gracious disposition in that vein
fellow John Wick chapter 3 Parabellum
star Halle Berry has been full of praise
for the action icon following their
collaboration Barry particularly took
note of his professionalism on the set
which he explained gave her a newfound
appreciation for the star anyone who has
seen Keanu Reeves in one of his many
iconic action roles already knows that
he makes epic fight scenes and
death-defying stunts look easy the
veteran action star is known for
training harder than most if not all of
his co-stars in many cases Halle Berry
as vouch for his incredible work ethic
on John Wick 3 in particular back in
2019 Reeves was memorialized for his
contributions to cinema at the TCL
Chinese Theater in Hollywood and Barry
was present for the occasion taking to
Instagram afterward Barry gushed over
her work Crush writing that the occasion
was a well-deserved honor for one of the
hardest working actors she's ever met in
fact Barry once revealed that she enjoys
working with Reeves so much that she
attempted to keep working on John Wick 3
even after breaking her ribs and
training in an interview with extra she
described feeling particularly motivated
to go above and beyond in order to keep
up with his impressive pace
pretty amazing it was a little
terrifying at first because he's so damn
good and
um I wanted to be on the same level with
him after breaking her ribs while
training for the movie Barry initially
kept working not wanting to be taken off
the film at her role recast but she was
grateful to direct her Chad's the
housekeeper instead waiting for her
injuries to heal before he resumed
filming Barry for her part described the
injury she sustained as a badge of honor
it turns out Barry had the opportunity
to work with Reeves many years prior to
John Wick 3 but passed on the role in a
video interview with MTV News Halle
Berry revealed that she was once offered
a role in speed a 90s Thriller starring
Reeves and Sandra Bullock when asked why
she didn't sign on to that film very
self-deprecatingly explained
yes my stupidity no stop however Reeves
was quick to defend Barry's decision not
to join the cast of speed after all the
script that Barry read didn't yet
feature Reeves as its lead and bizarrely
the bust didn't even leave the parking
lot with that premise Reeves said he
doesn't blame her for turning down the
roll right we can't leave this parking
lot if we leave this parking lot on the
bus it blows up of course I don't blame
you for like going
next by the time she was offered her
role in John Wick 3 however Reeves was
of course already attached to the
project in fact he was one of the
reasons she accepted Barry was already a
fan of the first two John Wick films and
had watched some of the videos of Reeves
training for his action scenes in those
films I've seen behind the scenes you
know clips of him and I saw his training
and I heard about it so I knew what I
was signing up for and that's largely
why I wanted to do it but far from Barry
being the only fan of her co-star's work
admiration between the two actors is
mutual during a press conference for
John Wick 3 Barry mentioned that she
just wanted to prove herself worthy of
sharing a room with Reeves but Reeves
quickly replied oh come on Hallie you're
an inspiration while John wake 3 remains
a sole collaboration between the two of
them judging by their mutual respect for
one another More film starring Barry and
Reeves together very well could be on
the way
if there's one thing that movie fans
everywhere seem to be able to agree on
it's that Keanu Reeves is a pretty
awesome guy but although his career is
going great nowadays Reeves once spent
over a decade blacklisted by one of
Hollywood's biggest Studios so just why
was he thrown into movie jail for 11
long years before you can really
understand why Keanu Reeves spent so
long out in the wilderness you first
gotta understand the events leading up
to his Exile and for that you've got to
start at the beginning of his career
after featuring opposite Rob Lowe in a
forgettable yet strangely successful
hockey movie called Youngblood Reeves
caught the world's attention with
River's Edge a controversial movie about
apathetic teens and the killing of a
young girl soon Reeves was showing up in
way bigger films such as Dangerous
Liaisons which starred the likes of John
Malkovich playing close Uma Thurman and
Michelle Pfeiffer then of course he was
cast as one of his most iconic
characters the laid-back time traveling
wannabe rock star Theodore Logan of Bill
and Ted's Excellent Adventure excellent
from there he went on to prove his
action skills by catching waves and
busting bank robbers in Point Break
granted Reeves also made a couple of
missteps early in his career for example
he proved to the world he's incapable of
doing an English accent with
back-to-back performances in Bram
Stoker's Dracula and Much Ado About
Nothing But by this point Reeves's
career was speeding forward nonetheless
and the actor was about to make a huge
leap from up-and-comer to Blockbuster
King
the year 1994 was pretty phenomenal for
film in general with the release of
Classics like Pulp Fiction the Shawshank
Redemption The Lion King and Forrest
Gump plus Adrenaline Junkies got their
fix with a whole slate of Awesome Action
flicks such as the crow True Lies Leon
the Professional and of course the movie
that made Keanu Reeves a Bonafide star
speed directed by Jan dabont speed
follows Jack travin a police officer who
finds himself up against a psychopathic
terrorist who's rigged a bus to explode
if it drops below 50 miles per hour
along with courageous commuter Annie
Porter travin has to Defuse The Bomb
catch the bad guy and save the day
really speed is everything you could
possibly want from an action movie
Reeves and Bullock have a whole lot of
sizzling chemistry the leading man did
most of his own stunts and yeah they
really jumped that bus as a result the
movie impressed critics turned Reeves
and Bullock into a-listers and earned
350 million dollars against a 38 million
dollar budget unfortunately there's
always a dark side to success and speeds
box office victory was about to send
Keanu Reeves to the Cinematic Slammer
when a movie enjoys as much box office
success as speed did what happens next
is pretty much inevitable and sure
enough the very week the money started
pouring in from speed Fox gave the
go-ahead for part two as a result
director Jan de Bond started reading new
scripts and sounding Out potential ways
for the story to go
inspired by a recurring nightmare in
which a cruise ship crashed into an
island dubont decided to set his sequel
at Sea the movie would start off with
Jack travin and Annie Porter as a
married couple with the two going on a
tropical cruise that is rocked by a
major terror attack courtesy of a
vengeful hacker who was fired by the
cruise line of course if you're going to
make a speed sequel you've got to bring
back your original Stars Bullock signed
the dotted line after Fox promised to
finance Hope Floats a romantic drama
directed by Forest Whitaker in which
Bullock plays a spurned housewife trying
to take charge of her life but if you
switch on speed to cruise control these
days you might notice that Keanu Reeves
is nowhere to be found instead Jason
Patrick is playing some new cop named
Alex Shaw so what's up with the
switcheroo why did Reeves say no to
speed 2. obviously Fox wasn't happy when
their star abandoned ship in the movie
studio immediately started spreading
propaganda about him saying he was off
touring with his rock band dog star
instead of making movies according to
Reeves however that couldn't be further
from the truth there were several
reasons why he didn't want to square off
against Willem dafoe's bug-eyed
terrorist but playing the bass wasn't
one of them so what did prevent Reeves
from signing on to the sequel well first
off he was all actioned out Reeves had
just finished filming on Chain Reaction
a thriller starring Morgan Freeman the
movie has Reeves starring as a scientist
who invents a new power source only to
find himself framed for murder and on
the run when the FBI comes calling
critics weren't crazy about the action
flick and neither was Reeves he
described the process of making the
movie as really unsatisfying lamenting
the fact that he had to do so much
running in action all in all it was a
disappointing experience for Reeves The
Experience left him exhausted and
unwilling to make Speed 2 so soon after
working on another action movie on top
of all that the star had also recently
broken his ankle in a motorcycle
accident so doing all the stunts that
would be required of him for cruise
control probably didn't sound like much
fun before casting Jason Patrick as the
lead in Speed 2 Fox offered Keanu Reeves
a hefty paycheck of 11 million dollars
to reprise the role of Jack travin but
Reeves turned them down not just because
he was tired of action films but also
because he had his eye on new more
exciting projects
Reeves was particularly interested in
playing the lead role in the satanic
legal thriller The Devil's Advocate this
movie finds Reeves playing a hot shot
lawyer from Florida who's invited to
join a successful Manhattan Law Firm
when he shows up in the Big Apple he
meets his new boss a devilish wheeler
and dealer named John Milton who seduces
Reeves's character into a life of sin
both in and out of the courtroom
The Devil's Advocate was filming at the
same time as Speed 2 cruise control but
in Reeves's mind it was a pretty simple
choice between the two he could act
across from Al Pacino and scream at
Satan in a penthouse suite or he could
get soaking wet doing aquatic stunts all
day long obviously the choice was easy
better to rule in Hell than swim in
speed too at the end of the day however
there's one reason above all that kept
Reeves away from cruise control he
thought the movie script absolutely
sucked in 2015 Reeves went on Jimmy
Kimmel Live to promote an upcoming film
and the talk show host asked just why
Reeves wasn't on that cruise ship with
poor Sandra Bullock Reeves answered
honestly it was just a situation in life
where I got the script and I read the
script and I was like ah of course trash
talking Speed 2 wasn't a new look for
Reeves as far back as 1997 he was
telling the Toronto Star that the script
wasn't great so Reeves bowed out and let
the speed sequel Sail On by and as it
turns out he wasn't the only one who
thought cruise control was a really bad
idea
according to many Speed 2 is the worst
thing that's happened to cruise ships
since the Titanic plowed into that
Iceberg hoping to recreate the success
of the original movie Fox Executives
gave director yonda Bond a budget of 100
million dollars for Speed 2. but to bond
Speed 2 still went over budget with some
suggesting the movie cost a whopping 165
million dollars to make the studio
poured a near endless amount of cash
into the high octane sequel but nobody
wanted a part 2 without their lovable
leading man so Speed 2 bombed Hard the
movie made 164.5 million at the box
office which is exactly what you don't
want to happen when you've just made a
movie with a budget of 165 million
dollars on top of that the critics
circled speed 2's Shipwrecked like
sharks and wasted no time in tearing it
to Pieces over on Rotten Tomatoes the
movie has a shockingly low approval
rating of just four percent with Speed 2
sinking in theaters it was suddenly
crystal clear that Keanu Reeves made the
right decision by staying far away from
the doomed sequel but he wasn't to his
escape the disaster without a scratch in
the wake of speed 2's disaster release
20th Century Fox apparently decided it
was time to Blacklist Keanu Reeves
speaking with GQ in 2019 the actor
claimed that the company tossed him into
what he called movie jail Banning him
from starring in any of their movies as
retribution for turning down cruise
control Reeves spent 11 years on Fox's
bad side and during that time the studio
released some pretty high profile films
such as X-Men The Phantom Menace and
Minority Report and you can't help but
wonder how different Reeves's career
might look if the studio had considered
him for any one of those projects sadly
Fox didn't shine at spotlights his way
until 2008 when Reeves played an
environmentally conscious alien in The
Day the Earth Stood Still and while he's
not in the Cinematic Slammer anymore
Reeves still doesn't do that many Studio
films these days the last time he worked
with one of the big companies for a
live-action leading man role was 47
Ronin with Universal Pictures and since
then he's taken to showing up in smaller
fare like the bad batch and the neon
demon even the John Wick movies are
relatively low budget Affairs
distributed by the independent
production company Lionsgate while we'll
never know what movies Reeves could have
starred in had he remained in Fox's good
graces the good news is that the actor's
career wasn't damaged too badly by the
whole speed to Fiasco just because Fox
didn't want to work with Keanu Reeves
didn't mean the other Studios wouldn't
either after all he was a hot young
actor with a whole lot of promise and in
1999 Reeves teamed up with Warner
Brothers for a weird little sci-fi flick
called The Matrix with its epic gun
battles leather outfits and fascinating
philosophical beliefs the movie landed
with the impact of a well-placed Kung Fu
punch and everybody started paying
serious attention to the man they called
Neo The Matrix revolutionized science
fiction gave birth to two sequels and
continues to influence pop culture to
this day in other words Keanu Reeves was
doing just fine without Fox
ensure there was a period post Matrix
where Reeves wandered in the wilderness
making a slew of subpar films like The
Watcher the lake house and Street Kings
but the guy was also making some
interesting choices too with quirkier
projects like Constantine and A Scanner
Darkly of course the Keanu Reeves
Renaissance really began when a group of
Russian gangsters broke into his home
killed his puppy and stole his car
people keep asking if I'm back and I
haven't really had an answer
but now yeah I'm thinking I'm back John
Wick was a sleeper hit that spawned a
franchise full of incredible fight
choreography Amazing World building and
some of Keanu Reeves greatest moments as
an actor today he's bigger than he's
ever been popping up in huge movies such
as Toy Story 4 making hilarious cameos
and quirky comedies showing up at
conventions and receiving all kinds of
adoration on the internet all that and
he never did have to do speed 2. could
have been worse
since Keanu Reeves first hit Hollywood
like a cool breeze in the 80s he saved
Humanity from robot slavery kept a doom
bus from exploding and even made out
with Paula Abdul
but even though Reeves is a pretty
prolific actor he remains far more
enigmatic than many other celebrities
until now here are some things you may
not know about Keanu Reeves
Bard brain
thanks to his roles as dumb guy Ted in
Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure and
dumb guy Todd in Parenthood Reeves was
in danger of being Typecast in the early
90s
now what that's why it was something of
a surprise when Kenneth Branagh cast
Reeves as Don John in his 1993 screen
adaptation of William Shakespeare's Much
Ado About Nothing But Reeves had
actually been performing Shakespeare for
years dating back to a 1985 production
of Romeo and Juliet at a Toronto theater
school and my own private Idaho was
based on Shakespeare's Works how much
does he love Shakespeare he turned down
a 12 million dollar offer to star in
Speed 2 so that he could play Hamlet in
a Stage production in Manitoba Canada
now that's love I had rather be a canker
in a hedge than a rose in his grace
haunted by a jacket while living in the
New York area young Reeves encountered
what can only be described as a ghost a
ghost jacket anyway there's really no
explanation so let's just have Keanu
tell the tell himself there's a doorway
all of a sudden we're looking over there
in this like jacket comes waving through
the doorway like just an empty there's
no head there's no body there's no legs
it's just there and then it disappears
and I was a little kid and I thought
okay well that's interesting and then I
looked over at The Nanny and she's like
this
whoa he can't quit smoking while smoking
is often a youthful indiscretion Reeves
was willing to adulthood before he
picked up the habit he says he started
doing it on the set of the 1996 comedy
feeling Minnesota
because his character was a smoker and
then he just got hooked
he's called smoking a prison that he'd
love to quit but can't personal
tragedies
Reeves endured multiple heartbreaking
tragedies in Rapid succession he met
actress and production assistant
Jennifer Sim in 1998 and the tooth fell
in love in 1999 Sim and Reeves were
expecting a child together but when Sim
was almost full-term doctors discovered
the baby had passed away the stress of
the loss of the child contributed to the
demise of their relationship less than
two years later while driving home from
a party at Marilyn Manson's house in Los
Angeles Sim was killed in a single car
accident
she was only 28 years old
charity work
Reeves is very close with his sister Kim
Reeves who was diagnosed with leukemia
in the 90s filming on The Matrix
Reloaded and The Matrix Revolutions was
reportedly delayed so Keanu could spend
more time with his sister and help nurse
her back to health in Kim's honor Keanu
has donated huge amounts of his time and
money to cancer Charities hospitals and
research facilities I have a foundation
that does some you know it's mostly
directed towards
you know health care and he also works
with organizations like the sick kids
foundation and stand up to cancer
film crew favorite while negotiating his
contract for the two Matrix sequels
Reeves scored a bunch of back end points
meaning he'd make a portion of the
movie's box office take in addition to
his salary
instead of taking all the cash for
himself reach diverted the money to The
Matrix trilogy's costume and special
effects teams essentially donating
Millions so the movies could be
completed after the production nearly
ran out of cash he also bought each of
the trilogy's 12 stuntmen a Harley
Davidson his way of saying thanks pay
cuts if Reeves really wants to work with
an actor he admires he isn't above
foregoing a portion of his usual salary
to help make it happen
he reportedly did exactly that so that
he could star in The Devil's Advocate
with Al Pacino and in The Replacements
with Gene Hackman What's it gonna be
Shane
I want the ball
winners always do
motorcycle man Reeves loves motorcycles
so much that he started his own business
the arch Motorcycle company whose
signature product is the arch motorcycle
KR GT1
designed and built with his friend and
Arch co-founder bike architect gar
haulinger the custom-built Superbikes
have two V-Twin engines and cost 78 000
each
rad Keanu Reeves has often been an
inspiration for memes viral pictures and
the overall Delight of the internet
among the most famous a viral video of
Keanu giving up his subway seat to
someone who needed it more
then this is uncanny 16th century
painting from the uffizi gallery in
Florence Italy which seems to suggest
that Keanu is actually a time traveler
himself and of course there's the
infamous sad Keanu meme which actually
made Keanu kind of sad
but not that sad I mean do I wish that I
didn't get my picture taken and while I
was eating a sandwich on the streets of
New York yeah not quite the wild
stallions
shortly after the release of the Bill
and Ted movies Reeves formed a garage
band called Dog star in his actual
garage I played in a band called Dog
star and we made a couple of albums I
played electric bass at their first gig
an up and coming band called Weezer was
their opening act and dogstar even
played The Tonight Show
if you didn't think you could love Keanu
Reeves more wait until you hear Academy
Award winner Octavia Spencer's sweet
story about the star throughout his
career Reeves has earned a reputation
for being one of the nicest guys in the
film industry whether he's quietly
giving up his seat on the subway or
helping fellow passengers on a flight
forced to make an emergency landing
ahead of its final destination as it
turns out Reeves who has seen a recent
career Resurgence thanks to intense
action movies like The John Wick
franchise as well as Charming cameos and
romantic comedies like always be my
maybe is also super nice to fellow
actors in need no matter the situation
during a socially distanced interview on
The Graham Norton Show the host who is
well known for drawing incredible
stories out of his guests asked the
hidden figure star to tell her Keanu
Reeves story and Spencer happily obliged
as Spencer told Norton her Reeves
experience was quite early in her career
when Spencer was headed to grab a script
for an audition she was dressed pretty
informally which she revealed to Norton
years after the fact it was about 25
years ago the Matrix that just come out
was on my way to pick up a script to
read for an audition though this story
seems innocuous at first it definitely
gets weirder from there as Spencer
revealed to Norton she was running
errands while pretty dressed down
wearing a worn see-through t-shirt
sweatpants and no underwear and her
outfit's not the only thing that wasn't
looking totally presentable that day my
car hadn't been washed because I always
parked underneath the tree and there was
bird crap all over the back of it
according to Spencer her car
unexpectedly broke down in what she
described as a posh area of Beverly
Hills leaving her stranded in the street
with cars honking all around her making
matters worse people at an outdoor Cafe
could see the scene unfolding but no one
helped her that is until Keanu hi I'm
Keanu Reeves
according to Spencer help arrived
suddenly in the form of a striking man
in sunglasses in a motorcycle helmet
whom she immediately could tell was
Keanu Reeves in the flesh while she was
quote freaking out about the celebrity
encounter Superstar Reeves humbly
offered his assistance I thought he was
going to get into the car I got behind
the car to push he said no I'm going to
push you out of the street you get in
pushing the car out of the street Keanu
didn't just help a stranger out he also
set an example just by being himself
according to Spencer when people saw it
was Keanu Reeves helping me everybody
came down to help now I know what it
feels like to be completely Starstruck
while Octavia Spencer may have been
having a bad day when she first met
Keanu Reeves the past 25 years have been
plenty kind to both of them in the years
since their first encounter both of them
have established themselves as two of
Hollywood's biggest stars after playing
a series of small roles in both film and
television Spencer's biggest
breakthrough came in 2011 with the help
a story which Chronicles the lives of
black maids in the South and the heavily
segregated era of the 1960s ultimately
Spencer won an Academy Award for best
supporting actress for her role and in
the years since she's appeared in other
high-profile projects like ma hidden
figures Get on Up and more meanwhile
Reeves Who Rose to fame thanks to films
like Point Break Matrix and villain
Ted's Excellent Adventure in the 1990s
has experienced a Renaissance in recent
years blowing audiences away with his
high octane stunts in the John Wick
films he also recently wrapped filming
on the long-awaited fourth Matrix film
where he'll reprise his leading role as
Neo and his promised audiences that the
sequel will be well worth the wait
whether Reeves is playing a wronged
Hitman or spoofing his own self-image on
screen you can't help but root for it
which makes it all the more rewarding
when you hear about this humble star
taking time out of his day to do a good
Good Deed first Ranger it's also a lucky
circumstance that Spencer's career took
off or we might never have heard this
story at all Reeves two huge upcoming
sequels The Matrix 4 and John Wick
chapter 4 are currently scheduled for
release in December 2021 and may 2022
respectively you can see Spencer in the
witches which is now streaming
exclusively on HBO Max
over the years marvelous populated its
sprawling Cinematic Universe with an
extraordinarily talented cast of actors
and actresses but the studio was still
never quite been able to grab Keanu
Reeves for a role and that's not for
lack of trying either so just why hasn't
Reeves shown up in the MCU so far
everyone knows Marvel likes to luck lead
actors and a hefty multi-picture deals
such as Chadwick boseman's reported five
film contracts and Sebastian Stan's
whopping nine movie deal and while
signing a Marvel movie contract comes
with many many perks there's no denying
that agreeing to film half a dozen
movies over the course of a few years
definitely cuts down on a number of
other projects an actor can take on
other actors like John Krasinski and
Emily Blunt have previously discussed
the projects they wouldn't have been
able to make if they'd taken a role in
the MCU and it's possible that Reeves
has had this on his mind whenever Marvel
approaches him about a roll in this case
it's likely that Reeves reluctance to
join the MCU is less about what Marvel
is offering him and more about the roles
and opportunities he could be forced to
give up
one such role could be the third
installment in the villain Ted franchise
although Bill and Ted face the music is
currently filming a third movie in the
Beloved 80s franchise has been on
Reeve's to-do list for a long time
since at least 2010 Reeves has been
openly discussing his hopes of making a
Bill and Ted three corn but the film has
taken years to get off the ground and
even once the movie finally looked as
though it might finally move into
production the journey hasn't been
without its obstacles particularly in
the financing and creative rights
Department with villain Ted 3 on such
shaky grounds Reeves may have been
reluctant to make a commitment to Marvel
that would have made face to music even
harder to schedule if making this movie
was indeed such a high priority for him
it makes sense that he wouldn't have
wanted to hand over such a large chunk
of his time and energy to Marvel before
it was finalized no one expected the
first John Wick movie to spawn such a
successful franchise Lisa volciano
Reeves when Reeves and Chad tahelski
were initially shopping around the
script for the first film they were
given a hard no by pretty much every
studio in Hollywood when they finally
did get to make the movie it was done on
a relatively tight budget of 20 million
dollars many of the artistic choices in
John Wick including the long takes and
close-up combat were made due to budget
constraints as a production couldn't
afford multiple cameras or fancy editing
but despite low expectations John Wick
went on to be successful enough to
justify two sequels with another on the
way the Bill and Ted and Matrix films
aside Reeves isn't typically a franchise
actor and the only other movie he's
worked on since the birth of the MCU
there hasn't been a standalone was Toy
Story 4. of course John Wick wasn't
intended to be any different but
considering the runaway success of the
John Wick films and Reeves ongoing
involvement as a titular assassin Reeves
may not want to sign up for another
major film franchise until he wraps up
the franchise he's already in in fact
that's exactly why he turned down the
part of young Rag and Captain Marvel
because he had to work on John Wick 3.
so the bad guy part went to Jude Law
instead and Reeves remained
tantalizingly Out Of Reach for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but it's not
just his long slaves of upcoming
projects that could be keeping Reeves
too busy to enter the MCU Reeves is a
man of many interests and talents and
he's doubled in a variety of professions
throughout the years in 2011 when the
MCU was first Gathering steam Keanu was
starting the arch Motorcycle Company
Reeves has been a die-hard motorcycle
Enthusiast for over three decades with
an extensive Personal Collection of
much-loved bikes that he's carefully
curated over the years Arch allows him
to feed his passion for motorcycles
creating custom high-end bikes that can
carry price tags of over 120 000 and
which Reeves has clearly tremendously
proud of outside of acting and
motorcycles Reeves has also played bass
in the band dog star written and
published books with artist Alexandra
Grant and produced a number of films now
it's not unheard of the MCU actors to
carve out time to pursue other endeavors
just look at Jeremy renner's singing
career and Mark ruffalo's tireless work
against climate change but it can't be
easy to balance outside interests with a
strenuous demands of an MCU contract
with so many irons and the fire Reeves
may enjoy the freedom of not being
logged into a multi-year Marvel contract
even if he's still able to squeeze
everything in around any potential
superhero gig the stress of juggling
them all may make it difficult to
actually enjoy any of them and if you're
not enjoying your passion projects
what's the point of doing them at all
beyond the demands of their long
contracts MCU actors also live under
constant and Relentless public scrutiny
in addition to starring in the movies
themselves they're expected to engage in
extensive promotion for Marvel's films
answering the same questions over and
over for an ever-ending parade of
journalists and talk show hosts and
while Reeves is an A-list star already
the notoriously private and introverted
actor may be daunted by the idea of
throwing himself into the MCU Limelight
speaking about Reeves to GQ John Wick
chapter 2 actor Peter Stormare has said
he's a loner they think he's putting on
some kind of a fake face when he's
stuttering giving interviews on the red
carpet and he looks away and looks
uncomfortable but he really is
considering just how many red carpets
Marvel actors have to walk it's possible
that Reeves has decided that being part
of the MCU just isn't worth being forced
to spend so much time in the public eye
due to marbles Reliance on returning
cast members and their movies demanding
production schedule the studio has never
been particularly eager to take risks
when it comes to its Stars not only
could injury and Juice production delays
throw their entire multi-year plan off
track but the cost of ensuring its
A-list Stars while they perform their
own stunts will be astronomical because
of this Marvel actors are contractually
prohibited from doing the bulk of their
own stunt work but Reeves is known for
doing most of his own stunts and may
indeed be turned off by Marvel's
Hardline policy speaking about John Wick
chapter 3 director and former Reeves
stun double Chad stahelski told GQ if
you've got an actor who can ride horses
ride motorcycles do fight scenes why not
I made a list of every skill Keanu has
we sat down and I said give me
everything you can do really well and we
put all that in the movies now that he's
accustomed to action movies that play to
his physical strengths and allow him to
Showcase his considerable action skills
it wouldn't be surprising if being
hamstrung by a studio contract seems
less than appealing to Reeves then
there's a chance that Marvel has been
offering him roles on exactly super
physical for example Reeves may have
made a great collector Everett K Ross or
even Steven strange but none of those
roles would have tapped into the sort of
physicality the actor is known for after
all it would be a bit of a letdown for
both the audience and for Reeves himself
if the actor known for doing 90 of his
action scenes and stunned heavy movies
finally took a role in the MCU and ended
up just standing there and waving his
hands for most of the time
being the huge fan of comic books that
he is there's a good chance that the
reason Reeves has been reluctant to take
a role in the MCU is because he's
holding out for the chance to play one
specific character in fact there are a
number of roles within the Marvel
universe that Reeves would be well
suited to play Adam Warlock the perfect
being teased at the end of Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 2 could be a good fit for
Reeves who let's face it is often
rumored to be perfect himself another
option might be Reed Richards the leader
of the Fantastic Four Disney recently
reclaimed the Fantastic Four from Fox
and with Tony Stark gone after the
events of Avengers end game the MCU has
a space open for a new scientist hero
along with the Fantastic Four comes
alien antagonist turned Ally Silver
Surfer who could also provide a meaty
role for Reeves or maybe Reeves wants to
play Ghost Rider a character that he's
always been a fan of and one that would
allow him to bring his love of
motorcycles to the MCU while this
character was already introduced in a TV
series Marvel's Agents of Shield it
wouldn't be a huge surprise if the
character was recast for the big screen
especially if Marvel could pull in an
actor of Reeves I better play him Keanu
Reeves has also told MTV in the past
that one of his favorite comic book
stories is Frank Miller's friend of
Wolverine due to Marvel's sale of the
rights to the X-Men to Fox in the 90s
mutants have never appeared in the MCU
so far that may be about to change with
Disney's recent acquisition of Fox at
San Diego Comic-Con in 2019 Kevin feige
recently hinted that mutants were indeed
on the horizon for the MCU which may be
exactly what Reeves have been waiting
for Reeves told MTV I always wanted to
play Wolverine I missed that one with
mutants now finally headed to the MCU
Reeves May finally get his chance to
sports a set of adamantium claws
at the end of the day however the MCU
may just have nothing to offer Keanu
Reeves a man who is already one of the
most beloved actors in Hollywood who
cares very little about money and
tourists by all accounts a genuinely
good person who frequently goes out of
his way to make the world a better place
for others
the feeling of of being there of walking
the streets of the future
is really going to be breathtaking
acting in the MCU can give a huge boost
to an actor's career catapulting them
from relative unknowns to some of the
most sought-after names in Hollywood
practically overnight but for an actor
like Reeves who's already a household
name with enough star power to pursue
pretty much any project he wants to make
that may not be much of an incentive to
sign up for a decade-long contract with
Marvel similarly Reeves doesn't exactly
need the MCU to endear him to the many
fans who already love him Marvel actors
are expected to be heroes both off and
on the big screen but Reeves doesn't
exactly need a studio contract to prompt
him to be generous and kind and he's
consistently reported to be among the
nicest people anyone could ever have the
pleasure of meeting
you're all breathtaking and that's the
Crux of it why you playing a superhero
when you're already one in real life
the internet has a lot of thoughts about
Keanu Reeves and so does Bridget
Moynihan so as the star of The Matrix
really as nice as he seems or are there
some skeletons in his closet one hand's
Revelations may surprise you when you've
worked in Hollywood for as long as Keanu
Reeves has your reputation follows you
around everywhere and in the case of
movie stars the public gets to have an
opinion about an actor's on-the-job
Behavior even if they don't have any
direct experience working with them in
the case of Reeves his General
reputation seems to be that of a quiet
humble decent guy who happens to be one
of the most famous people on Earth of
course it helps when he partakes in
delightful interviews where he answers
questions like a normal person and as
viral stories come out of the woodwork
about what a down-to-earth person he is
but as this reputation really accurate
every once in a while someone who's
worked with a star like Reeves will give
us a tidbit about what the experience
was like Bridget Moynihan best known
today as one of the stars of the police
drama Blue Bloods worked with Reeves on
both John Wick in 2014 and the sequel
John Wick chapter 2 in 2017. she played
his deceased wife Helen Wick whose final
Act prior to her passing is gifting John
fog so that he won't be as alone after
she's gone as anyone who's seen the
movies can attest that dog plays a
pretty Central role and during a 2014
interview she wasn't shy to share her
impressions of what Reeves was like on
the set one hand is no stranger to
sharing the screen with some of the
biggest names in the business after all
she joins Tom Selleck and Donnie
Wahlberg on Blue Bloods for the resume
that also includes the likes of
serendipity and Sex in the City it's
safe to say that Moynihan has been
around the block a few times and
generally knows what to expect when
working with A-list stars during her
interview with AOL Moynihan was asked
about a bevy of her famous collaborators
over the years including Al Pacino and
of course Keanu Reeves when asked about
how her experience of working with
Reeves on John Wick was compared to what
she expected Moynihan revealed he's very
quiet and very private I had always
heard that about him and he kind of
still was we had a really nice time we
were playing a couple that was in love
so that was really fun to do it sounds
like Moynihan didn't get a chance to get
to know Reeves too well despite playing
the Assassin's late wife and flashbacks
it makes sense given her role is killed
off pretty early in the film so she
probably didn't spend too much time
getting to know the legendary actor but
it also seems that her experience
working with Reeves was a positive one
he is after all one of the co-stars that
caused the Moynihan to declare during
her interview I had worked with the best
guys in the business when it comes to
actors one of the first things people
want to know is whether they're nice
there are so many horror stories of
celebrities acting like divas and
treating everyone they perceive as
beneath them like trash fortunately it
doesn't appear as though Reeves falls
into this Camp as several of his
co-stars have nothing but kind things to
say about him first there's his John
Wick 3 partner Halle Berry who took to
Instagram to gush over working with
Reeves on the project meanwhile Lance
Reddick who's played Sharon in all three
John Wick movies today Ted nothing but
nice things to say either the actor
described to a consummate professional
Reeves was on set and even went so far
as to declare whenever I work with the
big movie star for the first time I keep
my guard up to protect my work from an
ego and if there's any big movie star
who's not that person it's Keanu it
appears that if you're going to Star
alongside any A-list celebrity in a
major motion picture you want it to be
Keanu Reeves
when speed was released in 1994 an
action star was born since then Keanu
Reeves has appeared in a number of
action movies that have put his
abilities to good use some of them are
Stone Cold Classics While others aren't
here's every one of Reeve's action
movies ranked from worst to best
based on the William Gibson cyberpunk
novel of the same name 1995's Johnny
Mnemonic follows the story of a man with
a cybernetic brain implant that helps
him store information as is the standard
for Gibson novels Humanity's Reliance on
technology and the dystopian corporate
environment of this future keep people
in a kind of endless servitude Reeve
stars in the title role with supporting
performances from Dolph Lundgren and
iced tea sadly Johnny mnemonic's premise
just isn't exciting to watch despite the
action being pretty heavy as Johnny
tries to recover his own childhood
memories that have been replaced by
years of data smuggling the main
conflict loses tangibility and no amount
of action is enough to make us care
about his plight Johnny Mnemonic is
basically a guy running around a Sci-Fi
future trying to remember something he
forgot which doesn't exactly make for a
great cinematic experience
47 Ronin was one of the biggest box
office bombs of 2013. the overly
ambitious project reportedly fell victim
to a constantly shifting focus in
production and a lack of experience on
the part of first-time director Carl
rinch there was also a debate around the
project about the balance between
Eastern themes and a perceived need for
more Western touches one of those
Western touches was the addition of
Reeves to a mostly Japanese cast of the
film which retells an old legend about
47 Rogue Samurai avenging the death of
their Master what really brought 47
Ronin down was that despite its
well-choreographed fight scenes and
Slick use of 3D and CGI special effects
the movie was surprisingly dull with
little to no development of Reeves or
any of the other one-dimensional
characters but don't worry Reeves did go
on to make another martial arts movie in
2013 that turned out much much better
than 47 Ronin we'll get there
1996's chain reactions starring Keanu
Reeves and Morgan Freeman suffer simply
from being confusing Reeve stars as a
machinist who discovers some new
convoluted thing about hydrogen energy
before his lab explodes and he and his
colleague are framed for the bombing
Freeman plays the wealthy doctor funding
their project to whom they turn for help
though of course he turns out perhaps
inevitably to be the bad guy but much
like Johnny Mnemonic Chain Reaction has
no tether for the audience to grasp onto
for stabilization Reeves character is
framed for something that isn't clear
while Freeman's character is after
something that never really becomes
clear either it's a mess of a movie
who's only saving graces are a few good
action sequences there were a lot of
these formulaic action movies in the 90s
ones that all had something to do with
science or government or spies
unfortunately Chain Reaction wasn't one
of the good ones
the final film in The wachowski's Matrix
trilogy has the benefit of bringing the
Epic story to a close granting it the
opportunity to provide a rousing climax
enclosure to its philosophical Journey
sadly that didn't save it from receiving
the worst reviews of the series largely
because it sucks pretty much all the fun
out of the entire franchise not only
does revolutions end on a downer of a
conclusion with Trinity killed in action
and Neo sacrificing himself for peace
between the humans and the machines but
the final showdown turned out pretty
underwhelming in itself the program
known as agent Smith played brilliantly
by Hugo weaving wants to destroy the
Matrix the Machine World and the human
world for reasons that never really
become totally clear other than that
he's a broken Outcast and wants revenge
a rogue virus agent Smith was apparently
supposed to be deactivated but has
instead decided to make it his goal to
kill literally everybody
your life that taught me the purpose of
them all life
this life is
all this the characters we know and care
about get lost in a jumble of Side
characters overwhelming robot battle
sequences and convoluted plot lines The
Matrix movies can always be proud of
their seriously cool action scenes and
intriguing ideas but this one was a bit
of a bummer
Constantine is one of those movies that
should have been really cool but just
didn't live up to its potential based on
DC Comics hellblazer books Constantine
tells the story of a mortal human who
can see the celestial Angels and Demons
who infiltrate and manipulate Humanity
Rachel Vice co-stars as a police
detective whose sister's death reveals a
plot that upsets the balance between the
living and the dead the movies got a
great cast including an androgynous
Gabriel played by Tilda Swinton and some
of the fight scenes are really fun too
but ultimately the plot isn't one that
translates particularly well onto the
screen as a result the movie is
simultaneously convoluted and
predictable Roger Ebert gave the film
one and a half Stars while his TV
co-host Richard Roper wrote It's just so
awful that the crew must have been
snickering while 1999's the Matrix was
hailed as an exciting new entry into the
Sci-Fi genre with groundbreaking
filmmaking techniques its two sequels
weren't nearly as well received as that
first hit the two Matrix sequels weren't
great mainly because much like too many
other films these days they felt like
they should have been a single movie but
the plot had expanded and Bloated to the
point where the powers that be decided
too would be more exciting for audiences
the second movie in the trilogy 2003's
The Matrix Reloaded was praised for its
action and style but panned for its
portrayal of the humans who live in Zion
Humanities Haven outside of the Matrix
one Infamous scene in particular has
been subject to some pretty intense
mockery since the movie's release
foreign
that and reloaded's over-reliance on
philosophical conversations at the
expense of the action it simply ends up
failing to live up to the first Matrix
movie despite Reeves excellent fighting
skills
many actors end up dipping their toes
into the world of directing but not all
of them are any good at it thankfully
Reeves first directorial outing was
actually pretty decent Man of Tai Chi a
chinese-american martial arts film is a
love letter to the film star and Reeve's
stuntman friend Tiger Chen and is
inspired by his life and experiences Man
of Tai Chi came out the same year as 47
Ronin but managed to avoid the same
mistakes that brought that movie down
for one thing the movie actually
embraced its Chinese Roots cast and
environment rather than shoehorning a
white Western Viewpoint into an ancient
Story the critical consensus was that
Man of Tai Chi didn't do anything
groundbreaking per se but that the story
hearkened back to a style of martial
arts movie that hadn't been seen in
quite some time which Reeves lovingly
embraced and paid tribute to in his
directorial debut the New York Times
wrote the movie finds a janus-like Mr
Reeves looking in two directions at once
toward the old school kung fu movies of
Once Upon a matinee time and the modern
China emblemized by the high rises that
slice through the smogs swath Beijing
Reeves respect for China and the style
of filmmaking that served as a personal
tribute to his friend is on very clear
display here
if ever there was a spiritual successor
to Ted Logan of Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure it's Surfer FBI agent Johnny
Utah of Point Break the film directed by
Future Oscar winner Catherine Bigelow
tells the story of a gang of crooks
known as the ex-presidents because they
wear rubber masks of Nixon Reagan
Johnson and Carter while they rob banks
they also happen to be expert Surfers so
rookie undercover agent Utah infiltrates
their ranks eventually embracing his
Destiny as a Wave Rider in addition to
having some thrilling action and killer
surfing scenes Point Break is also a
lovely reminder of the acting Talent of
Patrick Swayze who passed away in 2009
from pancreatic cancer he was a
beautiful person an artist Patrick he
just wanted to experience life he lived
life to the fullest
granted both John Wick movies are great
and it's pretty hard to rank one above
the other John Wick chapter 2 comes in
just behind the first tier because the
first acted so well as a kind of
surprise comeback film for Reeves John
Wick chapter 2 begins just a few days
after the events of John Wick and finds
the former assassin continuing his
Rampage of Revenge only this time with a
new dog the film features just as much
Sleek well-directed violence as the
first film but John Wick chapter 2 also
takes a trip over to Rome for some
International Espionage among the
ancient ruins of the Eternal City
proving that WIC is truly a worldly
International assassin
whoever comes
whoever it is
I'll kill them
I'll Kill Them All
despite having starred in numerous
action movies John Wick might be Keanu
Reeves Grand Opus of a role this 2014
neo-noir action film tells the story of
a former assassin drawn back into a life
of killing after car thieves kill his
puppy who was a Memento left behind by
his late wife this rule is absolutely
perfect for Reeves whose Sleek looks
naturally stoic nature and incredible
action skills are all put to Great use
in the movie everyone was kind of
surprised by how good John Wick was and
how perfect Reeves was for the part it
was labeled as a career comeback for
Reeves whose star had kind of dwindled
in 2017 birth movies death wrote it
wasn't too long ago that critics were
bemoaning the presumed end of Reeve's
career as a leading man but the John
Wick franchise has helped bring Reeves
back into the spotlight and now he's
calling the shots you uh working again
you know I just sorting some stuff out
never before and ever since has a city
bus had such a grand movie moment speed
is the film that put Reeves on the
action radar and is still a great watch
25 years later Reeves stars as Los
Angeles SWAT officer Jack who boards an
LA bus that's rigged with a bomb that
will explode if the vehicle's speed
drops below 50 miles per hour Sandra
Bullock co-stars as a passenger named
Annie who takes over driving duties
while Jack tries to Defuse The Bomb and
save the other passengers speed's
premise is a tad ridiculous and there
are plenty of seriously unbelievable
moments throughout the movie but its
absurdity is overshadowed by the fact
that it's just so darn fun Reeves and
Bullock have great chemistry and his
action prowess here is accompanied by a
real sense of charm in acting charisma
this is the movie for which Reeves will
be remembered for the rest of his life
and Beyond it's also the franchise that
puts sci-fi Masters the Wachowski
sisters on the movie map by utilizing
new filmmaking technology and tapping
into the exploding internet Zeitgeist
The Matrix was able to become an action
movie for the budding New Millennium
Reeve stars as Thomas Anderson a
computer programmer who lives a double
life online as the hacker Neo as he's
contacted by Morpheus and Trinity he
finally learns the truth about the world
artificial intelligence has taken over
the planet and robot overlords use
humans for their bioenergy keeping them
in a catatonic State while their minds
believe they are living in the regular
world this false consciousness is called
The Matrix and Neo joins the quest to
free Humanity from its grasp the movie
used Innovative camera techniques to amp
up the many awesome fight scenes
including 360 degree camera movement and
extreme slow motion to make even more of
a mind Bender out of an already
interesting premise by utilizing Reeves
natural stoic nature and its Sleek
movements The Matrix became his best
ever action movie
there's more to Keanu Reeves than the
characters he plays and he's got the
fascinating life story to prove it
here's a look at just how the John Wick
star went from a high school dropout to
the captivating actor he is today
Reeves is Canadian but he was actually
born in Beirut Lebanon where his mother
Patricia Taylor a British costume
designer and performer met his father
Samuel Reeves but his dad was
essentially out of the picture by the
time Reeves was a toddler as a result he
basically went wherever his mom's career
took them they lived in Sydney and New
York and eventually they settled down in
Toronto Reeves definitely has a
multicultural background in addition to
his travels he was also exposed to
Chinese and Hawaiian culture through his
grandmother he has also said that his
mom taught in British mannerisms and
passed down some of those customs and
formal attitudes his upbringing may have
been unconventional but he definitely
became more cultured because of it
Reeves's mother was quite well connected
in her line of work as a result little
Keanu met lots of celebrities when he
was a kid his mother worked for David
Bowie and he also remembers spending
time with Emmylou Harris and Dolly
Parton apparently Alice Cooper even
babysat for him I remember that he uh
that there was fake poo in the fridge
that was apparently part are for the
course that's like an Alice Cooper right
there and I don't know it's pretty funny
if he did that we gotta yeah next time
if we talk to Alice do you remember
doing that oh I'm sure he remembers that
it's easy to see why Reeves became
interested in acting at a young age as
an early exposure to so many celebrities
surely made it seem like breaking into
Hollywood wasn't a far-fetched fantasy
if his mother could work her way up and
connect with some of the biggest rock
stars in the world why couldn't he
achieve his own dreams
Reeves is an exceptionally talented
actor but he was not the world's best
student over the course of five years he
attended several different high schools
when he was a freshman he wanted to go
to a school that was highly ranked for
academics but later he decided to
audition for Toronto's Etobicoke School
of the Arts he was accepted but
unfortunately he ended up getting
expelled he said that he enjoyed his
time there but he's also admitted that
he simply wasn't cut out for such a
structured academic environment Reeves
isn't the only actor in Hollywood who
didn't finish high school and like many
other creative young people he thrived
in alternative environments he also had
dyslexia which certainly didn't help
matters but he enrolled in a class
called respect for acting as well as
sketch and improv courses with Second
City Toronto and he continued attending
these classes at night and honing his
craft
Reeves is a man of many talents in
addition to acting in movies and theater
he's also spent plenty of time on the
ice playing hockey in fact at one point
in his life he hoped to play
professionally while attending De La
Salle College in Toronto he played
goalie and he was quite the formidable
opponent he was so skilled at netminding
that he earned the nickname the wall
when he was younger Reeves dreamed about
representing Canada in the Olympics one
day but when he decided to dedicate
himself to acting he put that dream on
the back burner he continued to play
hockey on a recreational basis but he
chose to put acting first Reeves may
have started out as a young Jack of all
trades but he chose to commit his life
to becoming a master of one and that
decision has clearly paid off one of
Reeves's first professional gigs was
working as a correspondent on the
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation youth
program going great the show focused on
child prodigies who were able to
accomplish amazing things at a young age
and how long did you do it
um they fired me after the first year
Reeves also appeared in another local TV
production called hanging in a scripted
series about kids who attend a
Counseling Center in a rough part of
Toronto he described hanging in as a
godsend for young actors in Toronto at
the time who were just trying to get a
foot in the door and make some
connections in the industry Reeves is
not just skilled as an actor he's also a
gifted musician and he was the bassist
in a band called Dog star in the 90s and
2000s the band got its start when Reeves
ran into vocalist Robert mail house in a
grocery store in 1991. the two bonded
over their mutual love of hockey and
eventually they realized that they both
liked jamming out together too two more
friends joined the band and as their fan
base grew they started touring They even
played some pretty big festivals like
Glastonbury in England the band broke up
after releasing their second album
because the members were getting busy
with other commitments in particular
Reeves's career was really taking off
with the popularity of the Matrix films
but this wasn't the end of Reeves's
musicianship as he and mail house would
go on to Prof together some more in a
band called Becky maybe he can whip out
that base in the next John Wick movie
shredding on some strings could totally
be a useful tool in an Assassin's
Arsenal
if you're wondering how Keanu Reeves
became the muscle-bound movie star that
he is today watch on as we look at the
intense training that has helped get the
actor into Master assassin shape Keanu
Reeves made his first foray into action
with the 1991 bank robbing Surfer flick
Point Break this not only meant that he
had to be capable of Performing stunts
and action scenes but that he also had
to learn how to surf according to
Entertainment Weekly Reeves and co-stars
Lori Petty and Patrick Swayze all spent
two months taking lessons from the
world-renowned pro-surfer Dennis Jarvis
as Jarvis explained Reeves had never
surfed before and all three actors were
beginners still even though Reeves was
inexperienced he gained a passion for
the sport and continued to serve as a
hobby surfing is a challenging sport
that Demands a great deal of strength
especially in the shoulders chest legs
and core while Reeves didn't necessarily
get super ripped for Point Break the
effort he put into learning to surf
surely moved him into a new level of
physical fitness and capability 1994
speed was the first movie where
audiences could see Reeves really pack
on the muscle and while we don't have a
lot of information on how he got in
shape for it we do know that he went to
extra lengths to perform some of the
most demanding and dangerous stunts
himself are you like the devil you know
Daredevil Adventures once in a while I
kind of dabble but not really not really
perhaps the most notable example of this
was the notorious busboarding scene in
which he leapt from a Jaguar onto the
speeding bus Reeves wanted to tackle the
stunt himself according to director Jan
dubont who told Entertainment Weekly
he was nervous in the beginning then he
got addicted to the adrenaline although
dabont told Reeves he couldn't do the
stunt himself Reeves practiced secretly
offset when it came time to shoot the
scene Reeves just went ahead and jumped
much to the director's shock
for many people The Matrix was the first
time they got to see Keanu Reeves in
full action star mode but it might
surprise you that despite all the action
scenes Reeves filmed in The Matrix
intensive workouts really weren't part
of his routine his character Neo was
never intended to be buff and even when
he was training for the martial arts
scenes he had to take it somewhat easy
due to a spine injury however that
doesn't mean Reeves didn't put in plenty
of sweat and effort according to Kung Fu
magazine Reeves and co-stars Lawrence
Fishburne and carrian Moss went through
four months of kung fu and wire work
training to ensure that they had the
martial arts skills necessary to nail
the complex choreography required to
shoot the movie's intricate fight scenes
Keanu Reeves has a much more modern
approach to dieting than a lot of his
fellow Hollywood celebrities speaking to
Men's Journal Reeves described his
training diet as low sodium low-fat and
the night before a big fight sequence I
still eat a steak it's a habit that he
began while filming The Matrix and that
he seems to indulge whether training for
a movie or not Reeve said that between
his films his diet doesn't change much
and that he enjoys steak red wine a nice
single malt with a big ice cube that
doesn't mean he doesn't maintain any
additional dieting parameters reportedly
Reeves tends to avoid over-indulgence
and sticks to foods like chicken steak
rice vegetables and pasta over the years
Keanu Reeves has frequently pushed his
body to the limits with Reeves in his
mid-50s it's important that he puts in
plenty of effort to avoid injury when
training the actor spends a lot of time
on stretching in warm-ups and his actual
workout routine tends to focus on
resistance bands and body weight
exercises which are easier on the joints
than free weights speaking to muscle and
fitness Patrick Murphy Reeves trainer of
25 years said keanu's body was put
through the ringer I had to implement
the safest most effective program
possible this meant focusing on a high
volume low impact routine with limited
rest in other words injury was avoided
by focusing on performing a high number
of repetitions rather than lifting heavy
weights it's safe to say that John Wick
is Keanu Reeves most physical role and
since the Assassin has to spend pretty
much all of his time fighting bad guys
Reeves has to be pretty ripped however
according to Men's Health Reeves has a
workout routine that's surprisingly
limited utilizing just six Central
movements the first is a reverse lunge
front dumbbell raise which is a full
body workout that hits the legs
shoulders and chest second is a bosu
lunge shoulder press in addition to
working out the lower body and shoulders
this particular technique is great for
developing balance third is a reverse
step resistance band row which continues
the lower body workout while shifting
the upper body emphasis to the back
fourth is a squat with TRX shoulder ISO
hold which is a squat variation that
hits the lower body and shoulders
movement number five is a stability ball
Dynamic plank which develops core
strength and balance the final move in
Reeves workout is a banded lateral walk
Paul off press which helps to develop
shoulder width and leaves mere mortals
feeling sore the next day it may seem
like a fairly light routine but it
ensures that Reeves is both strong and
mobile which comes in handy for martial
arts training while training for the
John Wick movies Reeves workouts have
tended to emphasize speed and endurance
over strength if you watch his fight
scenes carefully he's rarely doing
anything that requires major muscle but
instead he performs a series of Highly
intricate rapid movements over a long
period of time
to develop this capability Reeves moves
through his workout in a fast-paced
circuit speaking with Men's Health
trainer Patrick Murphy explained that
Reeve Cycles through his workout routine
about five or six times within an hour
and a half
according to Murphy he wasn't lifting
crazy heavy weights it was getting his
body moving getting his muscular
endurance and stability it was just a
mindset he would leave the gym exhausted
but feeling great as anyone who has seen
the resulting fight scenes knows these
efforts have paid off once the action
starts Reeves doesn't seem to stop
moving until it's all over
while Reeves performed some fight scenes
in Point Break and speed his first
substantial martial arts training came
while preparing for the Matrix according
to renowned martial arts trainer Yen Wu
ping we had to start from scratch
training him from the basics but he was
very hard working and put in a great
deal of effort Reeves martial arts
knowledge kicked up a notch for the
first two John Wick movies for which he
trained extensively in Judo and achieved
expert level skill this went even
further for the third installment for
which Reeves learned Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
according to director Chad stachelski
their approach was we're gonna sit in a
gym for six months and just get as good
as a sun guy not learn moves but
literally be trained as a martial arts
Sun performer that training began
several months before shooting and it
spanned seven days a week for four or
five hours a day
in an Instagram post from December 16
2019 Terran tactical wrote Keanu
starting his training for John Wick 4
and Matrix 4. Karen tactical is a
training company that helps actors like
Reeves learn how to realistically use
Firearms Reeves has trained with Terran
tactical before working his way through
elaborate courses and shooting AR-15s
semi-automatic pistols and
semi-automatic shotguns Reeves has
become an incredibly proficient shot
taking out all manner of targets and
with the additional training for his
upcoming movies it looks like we're in
for a whole lot more of the gunfu we've
come to expect from the actor
the John Wick series is a resounding
success with Keanu Reeves bringing the
retired assassin back for a third
feature-length Rampage there's no better
time to break down how the actor
prepares to take on the physically
demanding role you might be surprised at
just how intensely he works to become
John Wick
while watching all the insane stunts he
pulls off in the John Wick films it's
important to keep in mind that Keanu
Reeves is in his 50s yet he makes those
moves look effortless and as often as
they can get away with it yes it's
really him Reeves logged his first
screen Credit in 1984 before many of his
modern fans were even born since then
the man has given us Decades of badass
characters many of which helped prepare
him for his turn as John Wick
understandably he's starting to slow
down a bit as he gets older but he still
puts everything he can into his
performances he mentioned in a profile
in Men's Journal I can't do stairs as
fast but if you say action I'll go yeah
I'm digging on back
to prepare for playing John Wick Reeves
goes through what he describes as a
three-month John Wick boot camp to help
him get ready to take on the demanding
role the training regimen focuses on the
character's Central concerns fighting
driving and guns
lots of guns Reeves talked about the
routine in an interview with page six
revealing how he sharpens his shooting
skills before the camera's role as he
described it basically just take the gun
home start walking around practice
spying rooms practice your draws and
with John Wick it's practice your
reloads transitions from weapon to
weapon footwork and then kind of coming
up with the John Wick style Reeve said
he loves playing and training for the
role adding that he couldn't wait to
return for a third installment Reeve
said of WIC as a character I love his
will his passion I love the depth of his
feeling I like his honor I like how he
fights for his life I like his sense of
humor working
yeah
one defining characteristic of the John
Wick films is how effortlessly Keanu
Reeves carries himself around Firearms
he always seems totally in control
utilizing the smallest amount of energy
possible in order to take out his foes
there isn't a lot of film trickery
involved in his technique it's mostly
just Keanu being really really good at
handling guns in order to prepare for
playing an expert assassin Reeves works
with shooting Ace Taryn Butler a world
champion in many shooting competitions
who served as a consultant for several
different television and film
Productions and appeared on competitive
shooting shows like Top Shot and
impossible shots in his John Wick
training Reeves has spent time with
Butler at Taran Tactical Innovations a
training ground for competitive Shooters
if chapter 2 is anything to go by we can
expect the Gunplay to get amped up even
more in John Wick 3. John Wick also
possesses some seriously impressive
driving skills which is something else
Keanu Reeves practices in his
preparation for the role because of the
degree of difficulty involved in some of
the set pieces Stunt Driver Jeremy Frye
handles the most dangerous tasks like
pulling off the flying drift maneuver in
the second film however a big part of
Reeves's boot camp also includes working
with stuntmen to improve his own driving
skills for scenes behind the wheel the
fancy driving comes pretty naturally to
Reeves who's a bit of an Aficionado in
the realm of luxury Vehicles he's been
known to own a Porsche and several
impressive motorcycles in past films he
sat behind the wheel of Ferraris
Mustangs and some impressive muscle cars
of the 60s and 70s Reeves's trainers
claim that his driving significantly
improved from the first John Wick to the
second it seems logical that he'd
continued driving circles around
everyone in chapter 3. one of the
biggest problems with many modern action
films lies in the editing of fight
sequences whether it's to hide the fact
that actors can't really fight or not
many fight scenes today get edited to
the point where it's impossible to tell
what's happening but Reeve's impressive
martial arts resume helps the filmmakers
he works with craft much more impressive
fight scenes by allowing them to use
long cuts and show techniques that other
movies can't Reeves trained in multiple
different disciplines to perfect the
fighting style John Wick uses Jiu Jitsu
Judo and practical grappling techniques
are all mixed in with extensive gun
practice to make Wix abilities look
effortless the care Reeves takes to get
the moves right helps to save on money
time and editing decisions later on
director Chad stachelski spoke about the
Productions approach in the lead-up to
chapter 2 saying we're gonna do Judo Jiu
Jitsu and tactical gun works so he can
hold all the shots no Cuts Keanu
Reeves's workout routine for John Wick
serves a dual purpose for one it's
tailor made for Wix no-nonsense
explosive fighting style his character
needs ruthless efficiency not bulging
muscles so his workout is grounded in
that philosophy on the other hand Reeves
is in his 50s so his workout is tailored
more to strengthen his joints and core
muscle groups and have them working in
harmony Reeves's trainer Patrick Murphy
has said that the John Wick workout
mostly utilizes resistance bands in
place of free weights because they're
easier on the joints and help the body
learn more control he spoke about the
routine with muscle and fitness saying
that the focus was on quote unilateral
exercises like ice skaters and
single-led pistol squat hops which
enhance proprioception the body's
ability to sense what all its parts are
doing and balance part of John Wick's
massive success is due to its amazingly
choreographed and performed action
sequences they often read like dance
sequences and a big part of that is
Reeves's focus on nailing the moves
before the cameras ever roll
it turns out that Keanu Reeves has got
his eye on one particular superhero role
is it Ghost Rider Silver Surfer squirrel
girl you'll just have to keep watching
to find out after seeing him Dodge
bullets in one iconic franchise and send
them flying into henchmen skulls in
another Keanu Reeves fans have had High
Hopes he'll take the leap into the
superhero genre it wouldn't be his first
time of course back in 2005 Reeves
brought the DC hero John Constantine to
life in Constantine it wasn't the most
successful comic book movie ever but
Reeves has since expressed an interest
in reprising the role while that may
never come to pass it hasn't stopped him
from becoming a highly sought after star
for other projects in 2021 it was
confirmed that Reeves had met Marvel
head Kevin feige about finding a
potential spot for him in the MCU but
there's been no word on any development
since then however it seems there's one
other Avenue Reeves is willing to walk
down as it's been revealed he has his
eye on one particular DC role in fact
it's a character that Reeves himself has
recently tackled in the recording booth
in the newly released animated feature
DC's League of Super Pets Keanu Reeves
voices a somewhat more comedic iteration
of Batman although he might not be a
central character in the movie Reeves
has admitted that he has high hopes of
donning the legendary cape and Kyle in
live action it's been a dream but you
know there's uh Pattinson's got Batman
right now and he's doing awesome Robert
Pattinson hasn't crushed his Spirit
entirely though with the bat fan
hopefully he might get a call eventually
maybe down the road maybe when they need
an older Batman well there are a few
scenarios in which Reeves could play the
role throughout DC history a number of
non-bruce Wayne Batman have dared to
descend on Gotham's underworld what
gives you the right what's the
difference between you and me I'm not
wearing hockey pants
for example Keanu Reeves could find a
place in the live-action DC Universe not
as the billionaire playboy but as his
father Thomas Wayne who became a far
more vengeful vigilante in a different
timeline in the flashpoint story arc the
Scarlet Speedster found himself in
another timeline that saw Bruce Wayne
being killed in Crime Alley instead of
his parents this led to his father
Thomas donning a cape and Kyle as a more
brutal pistol-packing protector of
Gotham City to make matters worse the
tragedy LED his wife Martha to become
this timeline's Joker turning the
history of two famous foes on its head
failing that of course there's one other
Bruce Wayne that Reeves could bring to
life the Incarnation scene in Batman
Beyond while the actor may have been
joking when he suggested playing an
older version of the character that's
actually an idea Warner Brothers has
entertained before in 2000 the studio
considered adapting the Beloved animated
series Batman Beyond the show saw an
aged Bruce Wayne passed the cow to a new
protege Terry McGinnis from there the
new battle on the Block protected the
cyberpunk influence landscape of
neo-gotham as a capless crusader with
Wayne keeping a watchful eye over him
back in the early 2000s Clint Eastwood
was touted as the Prime Choice to take
on the role of the Yoji bat these days
Michael Keaton feels like an obvious
choice for the gig arguably though if a
live-action Batman Beyond project ever
started up again Reeves Action Movie
experience might make him a smarter
Choice whether Reeves plays an elderly
Bruce Wayne or grizzled Thomas Wayne or
something else entirely there are
clearly many ways in which he could take
on the role of Batman sometime in the
near future and hey if nothing else we
already know how good he looks in Black
foreign
Reeves is one of the world's most
beloved actors known for his fantastic
work in action movies like The Matrix
and the John Wick series though his life
has had its fair share of tragedies and
hardships that made him into the man he
is today
the emotional gut punches started at a
very young age for Keanu Reeves he was
just a three-year-old kid when his
father Samuel Reeves abandoned the
family leaving his wife Patricia to
raise their two children alone
predictably he and keanu's relationship
has devolved since then from Rocky to
completely non-existent in the 90s
Samuel was arrested for possession of
cocaine and heroin and received a
10-year jail sentence he's been out for
a good while but his relationship with
his son never recovered old men have
commented on their falling out in the
years since Keanu told Rolling Stone in
2000 the story with me and my dad's
pretty heavy it's full of pain and woe
and [ __ ] loss and all that clearly
despite the fact that the two men
haven't spoken in years the pain that
lingers between them endures given how
young Keanu was when his father left the
family that's a whole lot of time he's
had to spend dealing with difficult
feelings toward his father for his part
Samuel told the mirror keanu's made it
clear that he wants nothing to do with
me he went on to add I'm embarrassed by
it all piano said my life was tragic and
oh boy does that hurt sad yeah I never
figured things would end up this way but
he'll always be my boy
Reeves's newly single mother Patricia
moved frequently from state to state and
marriage to marriage though there's a
lot of love there this sort of constant
upheaval is hard for anyone to deal with
let alone a kid after Reeves's father
left Patricia took the little plan from
Australia to New York City Once settled
in the Big Apple she met and married
Broadway director Paul Aaron in 1970.
the couple moved to Toronto shortly
after sadly the romance didn't last but
happily enough Aaron remained friendly
with Reeves often giving him career
advice and helping him secure some early
acting jobs the Reeves Family remained
in the Yorkville neighborhood of Toronto
throughout much of the 1970s and into
the following decade in 1976 Patricia
married rock music promoter Robert
Miller but they unfortunately split to
1980. her next marriage the hairdresser
Jack Bond lasted until 1994 by which
time Reeves had become an established
force in Hollywood
as a kid Reeve struggled academically
attending four separate high schools in
total he never did earn his diploma and
never pursued higher education are you
going to graduate
Reeves was in fact expelled from one of
his many schools as he told the Daily
Mail in 2008 it was difficult I went to
four different high schools in five
years I was okay academically good at
English and creative writing I was on
the chess team he added some reasons for
the problems including the size of the
school and numerous conflicts with
students and staff saying I was one of
those why kids I asked too many
questions about everything I couldn't
stop even if it got me into trouble I
wanted my autonomy and if you wanted to
impose something on me then you and I
would have a problem still he took the
expulsion hard saying it's a terrible
letter to receive saying you can't come
back to school next year getting asked
to leave was very upsetting in the end
though it inspired him to get serious
about acting
by the late 80s Keanu Reeves was already
Landing some major enviable roles most
notably in the legendary goofball buddy
comedy Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure a few years later he embraced
mature films like 1990s I love you to
death and the following year is my own
private Idaho a drama about two Street
Hustler friends who embark on a journey
of self-discovery Reeves became fast
friends with his co-star in those two
films River Phoenix Phoenix was on a
similar career trajectory to Reeves at
the time having broken into serious
roles in the late 80s unfortunately as
is often the case with young celebrities
Phoenix struggled with the pressures of
Fame and ultimately turned to drugs on
October 31st 1993 tragedy struck when
Phoenix collapsed outside Los Angeles's
Viper Room nightclub and died hours
later at the age of 23. the tragedy
stunned Hollywood and Reeves in
particular as Reeves told the guardian
in 2019 Phoenix was definitely one of my
closest friends from that era we shared
an artistic sensibility River was just
so down to earth spiritual and a unique
artist yeah I miss him by the late 90s
Keanu had broken out of rising star
status and become a Bonafide leading man
this happened largely on the backs of
1994's speed in which he played a young
cop trapped on a bus that's set to blow
if it travels slower than 50 miles per
hour in 1999's The Matrix in which he
played a man who discovers the world
around him as a simulation it was around
this time that he met and fell in love
with Jennifer syme an actress and
personal assistant before long Jennifer
was pregnant however shortly before
Christmas 1999 Sim noticed she hadn't
felt movement from the baby in days the
two rushed to the hospital where
ultrasound tests revealed the worst case
scenario was indeed true time delivered
their stillborn daughter Ava Archer Sim
Reeves on December 24
1999. understandably this loss
devastated both parents as an anonymous
friend told the globe in 2000 he really
had his heart set on becoming the Dad
instead he and Jennifer are undergoing
grief counseling to try and help them
cope with their anguish the loss of a
child is one of the most intense
tragedies a person can endure inevitably
it takes a massive toll on relationships
especially the one between the child
parents this was very much the case with
Keanu Reeves and Jennifer sign sadly but
very much understandably the couple
split a few weeks after laying their
daughter to rest in January 2000.
despite this Reeves and sign remained
close after the breakup
on April 1st 2001 Reeves met Sim at San
Francisco's Crepes on coal a popular
brunch spot according to people
according to the sun she attended a
party at the home of Marilyn Manson that
evening for reasons unknown after being
dropped off at her own home she left
again this time in her own vehicle
shortly after 6 a.m Simon's Car slammed
into a trio of parked cars she wasn't
wearing a seatbelt and was thrown from
the vehicle she died instantly the
tragedies of losing his child and former
partner changed Reeves forever years
later the griefs still lay heavily upon
Him Reeves told parade in 2006 grief
changed his shape but it never ends
people have a misconception that you can
deal with it and say it's gone and I'm
better they're wrong when the people you
love are gone you're alone
Keanu Reeves should have been enjoying
the peak of his acting career in the
late 90s and early Arts however the
nearly backed back losses he endured
during this period cast a shadow over
just about everything he did on top of
that his younger sister Kim had been
fighting leukemia since 1991. this long
battle with cancer took an enormous toll
luckily she had the support of her loved
ones including her big brother according
to a 1999 article in Australia's Woman's
Day Reeves supported her through the
years following Her diagnosis sending
flowers and special messages to a sick
sister at least once a week Reeve said I
love Kim she's so brave and I want the
very best for her you can star and hit
movies but that's nothing compared to
going through what Kim's been through
fortunately for everyone involved Kim
Reeves went into remission in 1999. as
years went on Reeves began taking on
more serious roles the critics could be
merciless now we'll admit his attempt at
an English accent in 1992's Bram
Stoker's Dracula is not great I doubted
everything
even my mind
I was impotent with fear
I know but it and other Reeves
performances didn't Merit the tidal wave
of mockery the actor soon faced though
the first Matrix movie was a hit the
subsequent two were not as beloved
critics and fans alike began attacking
what they saw as Reeves's wooden
underperformance as protagonist Neo in
his defense most of the main characters
in The Matrix franchise have the same
deadpan expression no matter what's
happening but while Hugo weaving gets
the cackle and snarl as the villainous
agent Smith Reese's Neo simply doesn't
emote ever all these years later his
infamously low-key one-word catchphrase
remains memorable
whoa but that is one can easily argue
the point of the character luckily
Reeves has since found a comfortable
home in the excellent John Wick Series
where a subtle performance as a
grief-stricken terrifyingly skilled
protagonist makes a lot of sense plus
you're too Amazed by the incredible
fight choreography to Really Care much
one way or the other
Reeves is quite the philanthropist
although he doesn't like to draw
attention to this regarding one of his
charitable projects Reeves said in 2009
I have a private Foundation that's been
running for five or six years and it
helps Aid a couple of children's
hospitals and cancer research I don't
like to attach my name to it I just let
the foundation do what it does in
addition to his generosity Reeves is
also shockingly private largely shining
the flashy celebrity lifestyle as a
result of all this generosity and
humility Reeves his reputation as
drastically transformed in recent years
he's gone from being dismissed as a
moderately talented action star to a
beloved figure of Hollywood all this
sudden adoration might seem a bit much
but it's not going anywhere anytime soon
the story of a man who's been through so
much only to remain a generous quiet
person is just too wholesome for the
internet not the Faun over
Keanu Reeves hit Hollywood like a cool
breeze in the 80s that's what his name
means in Hawaiian and ever since he's
been one of Cinema's most intriguing and
versatile actors but is his poetry any
good was Alice Cooper really his
babysitter here's the Untold Truth of
Keanu Reeves
when Reeves went to The Late Show in
December 2021 to promote his return as
Neo in The Matrix resurrections Stephen
Colbert took upon himself to divert the
conversation a bit and ask him about sad
Keanu an immensely popular meme based on
a 2010 picture of Reese suddenly eating
a sandwich on a bench Reeves explained
his State of Mind at the time of the
iconic meal I was thinking I had some
stuff going on sure I was hungry like
any of us Reeves was just trying to fill
his stomach and Ponder the complexities
of Life while doing so but he
inadvertently provided the internet with
one of the most viral memes of all time
back in 2011 when the meme was still
pretty fresh she told BBC how he really
feels about it do I wish that I didn't
get my picture taken and while I was
eating a sandwich on the streets of New
York yeah living is something that Keanu
Reeves has been doing for a long time
the actor was born in 1964 but some
people on the internet have come to
believe that Reeves is a whole lot older
than 57. in 2010 a Reddit poster noted
that there is a striking resemblance
between Reeves and portraits of Paul
Mooney a french actor who died in the
early 20th century about body was never
found not long after the post began
drawing attention someone made a small
addition to Monet's Wikipedia page
writing he currently acts under the
pseudonym of Keanu Reeves a source of
his eternal youth is not known the
addition went unchanged for several
weeks and Reeves's immortality
conspiracy was born it didn't take long
for the official Keanu Reeves's Immortal
website to enter the scene the site
features pictures of Reeves throughout
the years and he does appear to age at
about the same rate as Paul Rudd in
addition to Monet Reeves is also
confirmed to have been King Charlemagne
who lived from 748 to 814 and crowned
his son as king shortly before dying and
undergoing a rushed winter burial
It's a Small World After All Keanu
Reeves might have played in dog star
through the 90s but his connection to
rock and roll goes back way further than
that in an interview with Jimmy Fallon
Reeves confirmed that Alice Cooper used
to babysit him as a kid Reeves explained
that he grew up in Toronto just down the
street from a recording studio called
Nimbus nine Reeves's mother was a
costume designer who often worked with
musicians and she happened to have a
connection with Alice Cooper Reeves
confessed that he doesn't actually
remember spending any time with the rock
legend he said that's so rare I mean I
don't know how that could actually
possibly happen so but it did supposedly
yeah the only part of the experience
that Reeves can recall is a prank that
Cooper pulled he recounted I remember
that he uh that there was fake poo in
the fridge of course actors and rock
stars cross paths all the time but it's
not often that their encounters lead to
a story this delightful
everyone has to start somewhere and
Keanu Reeves got a start in the movie
business partially against his will when
he was still just a teenager Reeves's
stepfather Paul Aaron was working on a
second feature film The Summer that
Reeves turned 15. Reeves told the
guardian it was my summer holiday from
school and for parents it's like what do
you do with this kid over the summer I
know it will make him a production
assistant on a movie a force of one
starring Chuck Norris wasn't the most
auspicious start to a film career but
the job got reused invested in the magic
of making movies Reeves said I was
watching the grips I was watching actors
I was seeing how a film set really works
he spent weeks learning the ins and outs
of a film set but mostly he fetched
buckets of ice to keep the drinks and
snacks cool still he learned his most
important lesson about filmmaking on
that set he said a movie is all hands on
deck I love all hands on deck that love
has never left Reeves and neither has
his work ethic during the production of
John Wick 4 Reeves blew up online yet
again when someone caught footage of him
lugging heavy equipment around like
another crew member 42 years later
Reeves is just as hard-working as ever
and one of Keanu Reeves's earliest roles
he plays a hard-working cyclist who
Powers through a long race and gets
rewarded with a cool glass bottle of
Coca-Cola hey I'm proud of you really
proud
s reminisced about the role on The Late
Late Show with James Corden and the
memories brought a wide smile to his
face the three-day commercial shoot was
one of Reeves's first taste of being a
working actor and all these years later
he can still enthusiastically recall the
excitement and camaraderie that he felt
on the set with Reeves's reputation for
being one of the most hard-working
actors in Hollywood it will probably
surprise no one that he shaved his legs
for the role there aren't many actors
even at the beginning of their careers
who would go that far for a minute-long
coat commercial because of his starring
roles in major Hollywood Blockbusters
people often think of Keanu Reeves as an
American movie star but that couldn't be
further from the truth if anything
Reeves was more of an international Man
of Mystery Reeves was born in Lebanon
after his parents english-born Patricia
and Chinese Hawaiian Samuel met on a
beach in Beirut shortly after Reeves's
birth a family moved to Australia and
not long after that his parents
separated ultimately Patricia relocated
the family to New York for a brief stint
before settling in Toronto Reeves has
been a Canadian citizen for most of his
life though his frequent trips to Los
Angeles and other parts of the world of
obscure that pack for most of his fans
when he was asked in an interview why he
keeps his Canadian citizenship despite
spending so much of his time in the
United States he said I sometimes wonder
I've even regretted not having an
American citizenship especially at
election times though Reeves clarified
that he isn't an activist he does have a
strong belief that elections are
important he said ideally I would take
out dual nationality dual citizenship
might be Reeves's preference but with
over 100 acting roles in under 40 years
he's hardly had the time to enjoy his
Canadian citizenship much less seek out
another countries
when a famous actor pivots into writing
a book or a series of poems the results
are usually mixed at best Keanu Reeves
used The Stereotype to his Advantage
with his first poetry book Ode to
happiness which was published in 2011.
each page contains a single line from
Reeves paired with an illustration from
his girlfriend artist Alexandra grant
grant told the BBC that Ode to happiness
began its life as a joke she said her
friend sat at keanu's house one night
listening to wonderfully sad
self-pitying songs and Keanu in the
spirits of poking fun at them began to
write a poem the book begins with the
line I draw a hot sorrow bath in my
despair rooms it then continues on in
that self-serious vein for the duration
Reeves is the first to acknowledge that
the overwrought style of the poem isn't
meant to be taken seriously Reeves told
BBC it's only personal in the sense of
looking out and regarding my sense of
humor I don't usually take baths in my
despair room with a misery candle
burning the collaboration was so
successful that it led to a second book
in 2016. channels once again pairs
poetry with art but this time the
coupling Isn't So humorous Reeves told
the guardian that the book was is an
attempt to quote contextualize the grief
that he's faced in his life he hoped
that by writing about the grief he could
quote even be inspired by it to even
find a certain pleasure in it
as it turns out poetry just wasn't
enough to satisfy Reeves's seemingly
bottomless artistic Drive in the fall of
2017 he sat down with boom Studios to
talk about a character and story idea
that had been lingering in his mind for
ages the meeting was the most
keanu-esque pitch imaginable he acted
out various scenes from the story which
follows an immortal hyperviolent man
constantly engaged in combat and showed
off his Decades of fighting knowledge
Reeve said it went comic book I went
yeah why not and with that Berserker was
born Reeves paired off with veteran
comic writer Matt kin the Mind behind
mind management to bring his story to
fruition the comic features an 80 000
year old man who in keanu's words could
punch people's chests and their backs
and rip people's arms off to life the
story was planned as a 12-issue
miniseries and boom launched a
Kickstarter campaign to gauge interest
in the story The Studio ended up with
1.5 million dollars in pre-orders the
wildly successful comic is already being
considered for a film adaptation and
Reeves has stated that he would love to
play the role the project still needs to
find its perfect director but it likely
won't be long before Berserker hits the
big screen
though it wasn't his first time fighting
his way through scenes and set pieces
Keanu Reeves became known as an action
movie star after the Matrix I know Kung
Fu
[Music]
show me the film came out more than 20
years ago but as he's gotten older
Reeves has continually up the ante the
John Wick films directed by Reeves's
Matrix stunt double chance to helski are
filled with the type of visceral action
that usually relies on camera tricks and
highly trained martial artists however
Reeves famously prefers to handle the
material himself it's old Sunday today I
do all of the action I'm 90 of what's
happening there he says that doing
action scenes in his 50s is more about
recovery than when he was younger but if
anything he's gotten better with time
Reeves doesn't constrain his action
prowess to a single franchise either he
shot some pretty incredible stunts for
his return to the Matrix and the Matrix
resurrections Reeves told Stephen
Colbert on The Late Show that he and
Carrie Anne Moss jumped off a 46-story
building 19 to 20 times to nail down the
perfect shot when asked why he didn't
use CGI for the job Reeves said because
it's Lana Wachowski and it's the Matrix
and you need natural light and you want
to do it real adds a dedication of
someone who shaved their legs for a
commercial growing stronger with each
new opportunity
after all the time that Keanu Reeves has
spent in front of the camera it seems
only appropriate that he's gotten an
opportunity to sit in the director's
chair 2013's Man of Tai Chi Stars tiger
who chin as a young martial artist who
gets in too deep in an underground
fighting ring Reeves not only directed
the film but also stretched his acting
range by starring as the film's main
antagonist the film wasn't nearly as
groundbreaking as previous Reeves
outings but the critical consensus on
Rotten Tomatoes calls it an agreeably
old-fashioned picture for martial arts
fans and a solid debut for first-time
director Keanu Reeves Reeves hasn't
directed a second film but that doesn't
mean he won't Berserker writer Matt
kinned as thrown Reeves his name into
the hat for directing the comics film
adaptation telling the Washington Post
there's no one better to pull it off
than him
Keanu Reeves has acted in more movies
than most people even aspire to but
don't let that trick you into thinking
that he's going to disappear from the
big screen anytime soon Reeves told the
guardian around the time I hit 40 there
was this idea of creating more for my
artistic loins he said that he often
thinks about life like it's a reel of
tape when you're young you have a big
old reel of that tape left right and so
it appears to revolve slowly then time
passes and there's less and less tape
left on the reel it spins faster it
spins faster these days Reeves is trying
to move just as fast as a spinning tape
he's revisiting old franchises like the
Matrix and Bill and Ted while continuing
to push forward on more recent hits
notably there are currently two John
Wick sequels in production at the same
time he's releasing poetry showing up in
video games and spending time with the
people closest to him he said work
doesn't slow time down if anything it
speeds everything up luckily for us
Reeves still has plenty of tape left on
his reel
Keanu Reeves's career stretches right
back into the 1980s man well let's just
say he's had his fair share of ups and
downs from killer action flicks and
heartwarming dramas to tacky Thrillers
and cheap sci-fi these are the best and
worst Keanu Reeves movies
everyone knows that a dog is a man's
best friend so when a group of Russian
gangsters break into John Wick's home
kill his puppy and drive off in his car
he does what any notorious assassin
would do he makes it his mission to hunt
these men down and Destroy them but make
no mistake John Wick is more than just a
montage of mindless fight scenes the
cinematography is striking the pacing
will keep you hooked and the World
building is genuinely intriguing on top
of that Reeves's performance is a man
haunted by grief and loss is absolutely
top-notch and it doesn't exactly hurt
that he Nails the action sequences
either so far the original film has
spawned two sequels John Wick chapter 2
and John Wick chapter 3 Parabellum both
movies have earned positive receptions
from critics and audiences and the story
is even set to continue in May 2022 with
another installment John Wick chapter
four yeah I'm digging on back
and for the record every single film in
the franchise so far really has been
amazing so if you want to see Reeves as
action star best this is the place to
start
in the iffy romantic crime Thriller
Siberia Reeve stars is Lucas Hill an
American Diamond Merchant who lands
himself in trouble after traveling to
Russia to sell a rare variety of blue
diamonds to the gangster Boris volkov it
kinda seems like Lucas should have
anticipated that this transaction
wouldn't work out in his favor and sure
enough when he arrives he finds that his
contact with the diamonds has
disappeared now Lucas is desperate to
track him down before Boris comes
looking for what he's owed you'd be
forgiven for assuming that a film
involving a diamond Heist and a
forbidden romance would bring a little
more excitement to the screen than
Siberia does but sadly this movie's plot
is kind of plotting and dull but what
makes Siberia so frustrating is how
seriously this film takes itself you
can't even look at it as the kind of
movie that's so bad that it's actually
good much like an actual Trek through
Siberia the entire journey is a long
slog from beginning to end and you
wouldn't be blamed for wanting to give
up halfway through
one of the all-time classic comedies
Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure
follows the long strange journey of high
school Slackers Bill s Preston and
Theodore Ted Logan their High School
slacker struggling to pass their
upcoming history test and even worse
Ted's father is making plans to ship him
off to military school if he can't earn
a decent grade of course doing that
would alter the course of the future as
these two are destined to save all of
humanity with their rock and roll music
so Rufus a citizen of the future travels
back to the past to help them Ace their
test as a result the heroic Duo ends up
going on a time traveling adventure
enlisting familiar historical figures to
help them pass their test it's a
fantastic premise and even though it's
one of his earliest films Reeves is
absolutely fantastic proving he's a more
than capable comedy actor of course if
you need more Bill and Ted in your life
never fear Excellent Adventure inspired
two more sequels Bogus Journey and bass
to music and who doesn't need a little
more Bill and Ted in their lives
excellent
and exposed Reeves plays Detective Scott
Galvin a man who's trying to uncover the
mystery behind the shocking death of his
corrupt partner detective Joey Cullen
however Cullen's colleagues worry that
digging into his past will result in bad
PR for the police department
Thanksgiving stranger when Galvin
realizes that a young woman named
Isabelle was seemingly no prior
connection to Cullen might be involved
with the case somehow unfortunately
exposed was pretty much doomed from the
get-go the film was originally titled
daughter of God and the plot was
supposed to focus predominantly on
Isabelle and her family with the studio
behind the movie decided that centering
the storyline around Reeves's character
would result in higher returns at the
box office the film went through a
number of substantial changes in
post-production resulting in a very
different movie than the one the
director had initially planned it's
clear that this was a misstep in the end
and it's a real shame that the original
narrative never saw the light of day
my own private Idaho stands out from the
rest of Reeves's earlier work in
Hollywood it's Loosely based on a series
of Shakespeare plays but director Gus
Van Sant adapted The Bard's classic tale
into a Thoroughly Modern story even now
it's regarded as a classic example of
new queer Cinema and while the subject
matter wouldn't be viewed as
particularly taboo today it definitely
pushed boundaries back in the early
1990s the film was also notable for its
creative avant-garde visual style as for
the plot Reeves and his real-life ran
River Phoenix co-stars the wandering
protagonist Scott Mike these two friends
work as Street hustlers in Portland but
when Mike decides that he desperately
needs to find his mother they set off on
a journey that takes them all the way to
Italy Mike finds himself falling for
Scots and the two have to navigate the
intense emotions tied up in their
complicated relationship as a result the
film is very different from Reeves's
more action-heavy movies but it proved
to a skeptical world that the actor
really did have some serious dramatic
chops replicas was universally panned by
critics and it wasn't much of a hit with
audiences either to be fair to Reeves
though he was probably the only bright
spot in this practically unwatchable
film but tries he might his performance
just couldn't Salvage This truly dire
movie Reeves plays William Foster a
neuroscientist who Ventures into some
pretty unethical territory while caught
in the throes of grief after his wife
and children die in a car crash she
decides to try cloning them he knows he
has to keep this experiment to secret
but he can't hide it forever and
naturally this risky decision comes with
some unintended consequences admittedly
the idea behind replicas is actually
quite interesting and with better
execution this could have been a far
more engaging film but with numerous
plot holes and a cast of characters who
just can't seem to stop themselves from
making the worst possible decision in
every scenario watching replicas becomes
little more than an exercise in
frustration
speed was one of Reeves's first major
Blockbuster films and was arguably the
movie that catapulted him to Superstar
status Reeve stars as Jack traven a SWAT
officer working with the LAPD Jack and
his partner think they've managed to
stop extortionist bomber Howard Payne
after he attempted to hold a group of
elevator passengers for ransom as it
turns out however pain is also rigged a
bus with a bomb and if the vehicle's
speed drops below 50 miles per hour it
will explode and kill everyone on board
now it's up to Jack to defuse the
explosive and get everyone to safety
admittedly the premise of speed comes
across as kind of silly but as the movie
picks up it's nearly impossible to look
away from the screen the genuinely
sizzling on-screen Chemistry Between
Reeves and his co-star Sandra Bullock
certainly didn't hurt either and then of
course there's the bus jump one of
Hollywood's best ever driving stunts and
it was totally real too
foreign
all in all this is Reeves at his 90s
best just don't mention the sequel
based on a William Gibson story of the
same name Johnny Mnemonic sees Reef Star
as its titular character the plot is
clever enough Johnny has a cybernetic
brain implant that can store all kinds
of information and in a dystopian
Society ruled by Mega corporations where
everyone is forced to be connected to
the internet his abilities come in very
handy indeed in Johnny's World
transmitting sensitive data can be
dangerous so as a mnemonic Courier it's
up to him to carry certain information
to different parties however doing so
means risking losing his childhood
memories and he wants to remove his
implant to get them back unfortunately
for Johnny however his work isn't quite
done yet Johnny Mnemonic didn't exactly
get a glowing response from the critics
in fact Reeves actually earned himself a
Razzie nomination for worst actor so
it's safe to say that this role was a
new low point in his career although it
was marketed as an exciting cyberpunk
Thriller the plot Falls totally flat and
worse still it is aged very badly indeed
even for a 90s film sadly there's just
nothing all that memorable about the
futuristic world of Johnny Mnemonic The
Matrix was more than just the film it
was a cultural phenomenon the movie won
four Academy Awards and left a lasting
impact on an entire generation of
filmmakers and while Reeves was already
a well-known actor when the Matrix was
released this film brought his career to
a whole new level in this masterpiece
from the Wachowski sisters Reeve stars
is Neo a hacker who's unknowingly living
in a dystopia where Humanity has been
trapped in a simulated reality called
The Matrix this simulation was designed
by machines so they could control human
beings by keeping them in pots all while
harvesting their bodies for energy when
Neo discovers the truth about his world
he's given a choice he can take the blue
pill and return to his old life or he
can take the red pill and finally accept
reality and even though he knows he can
never truly go back Neo nonetheless
steps up to lead the Rebellion Against
the Machines the resulting movie is full
to the brim with philosophical musings
incredible martial arts fights and some
of the most recognizable and iconic
quotes in cinematic history
I know Kung Fu
show me The Matrix also gave audiences a
truly classic villain and agent Smith
gifted film fans with one of the coolest
opening scenes ever plus one of Cinema's
craziest gunfights the movie
revolutionized Hollywood with its
innovative camera work and brought
Newfound Fame and respect to Reeves
himself who delivered a fascinating
zen-like performance honestly The Matrix
isn't just one of Keanu Reeves's
greatest films it's one of the greatest
science fiction films of all time
Generation Um however might just be the
worst out of Reeves's entire career even
the title is underwhelming and things
don't exactly improve from there this
Mumble core Indie flake was so
unwatchable that it actually managed to
score a whopping zero percent on Rotten
Tomatoes in Generation Um Reeves plays
Jon an escort service driver who's lost
all sense of direction in life the film
explores 24 hours of his aimless
existence in New York City in which he
meets up with two young women Violet and
Mia this is an attempt to delve into the
concept of urban alienation but the
movie Falls far short of its attention
in one scene for example Jon points a
camcorder at the women and asks them to
say something interesting neither offers
up anything particularly poignant and
that basically sums up the film as a
whole in the end this movie is basically
a shrug of the shoulders and it quickly
comes to the tired conclusion that young
people these days just might be a little
Vain and self-absorbed not exactly
revolutionary stuff is it
from Neo to John Wick viewers just can't
stop hitting pause and analyzing frame
after frame of Keanu Reeves movies there
are too many Unforgettable moments to
count throughout his career but these
are the ones that truly Stand Out Above
the Rest while the famous proverb States
Hell hath no fury like a woman's scorn
it may have to be updated to say Hell
hath no fury like John Wick after you
kill his puppy when we meet this former
Hitman he's living a quiet life of
retirement while grieving his late wife
but after the bloody assault on his new
beloved pet he understandably desires
Revenge so he smashes open his basement
floor in order to access the secret
cache of weapons he's buried beneath his
home thus irrevocably plunging him back
into the world of Assassins this
particular scene is frequently paused by
fans because it makes you wonder what
exactly is WIC going to do with that
Sledgehammer that he just happened to
have lying around this moment also shows
the grief and desire for vengeance that
consumes him along with the fact that
the dog was a present from his wife
whose death left him completely
shattered the sledgehammer is the
viewer's cue that this seemingly slow to
anger guy is about to go ballistic the
full weight of everything Wick has been
going through loss Sadness the need for
Retribution makes this clip among the
most Paws worthy of Reeves's entire
career
who can resist soaking it all in when
someone demonstrates how lethal a pencil
can be in John Wick chapter 2 the
immediate aftermath of his takedown of a
couple of assassins in a coffee bar gets
us so hyped up that we simply must
rewind and repeatedly digest Reeves's
awesomeness after a multi-million dollar
Bounty is taken out on Wick he's forced
to fight off a posse of killers who step
up to claim the Booty by closing the
open contract on his life in this game
of assassin pretty much everyone is
willing to take a shot for that much
money no matter how well respected the
target is Wick is able to fend off his
attackers by eliminating them with a
simple pencil proving a writing device
can indeed be mightier than a sword
he was
once but with a pencil I know I've heard
the story fans of the WIC franchise
might want to take a break at this
moment to drink in the full scope of the
impressive display of violence that's
just been Unleashed not only does Wick
and two men after he's been wounded he
adds to his own lore about how he killed
three men in a bar with a pencil
witnessing him actually performed this
feat confirms that he's a badass capable
of turning just about any seemingly
innocuous object into a deadly weapon
the image of him holding the bloody
pencil after doing the deed sums up the
emotions we experience while watching it
things get even dicier for John Wick in
his third film when he finds the Elder
who's essentially the leader of the
underworld he's given a choice die
immediately or pledge loyalty to the
high table he chooses the latter option
so he then removes his finger and gives
his wedding ring to the Elder as a show
of fealty this is easily one of the
coolest scenes it demonstrates how
Wick's desire for a peaceful life is
often forced to take a back seat to the
seemingly endless obligations incurred
by his history of Underworld violence so
why is this scene worth pausing it's all
about the graphic intensity and the
artistic culmination of so many plot
elements Wick's commitment to honoring
the memory of his wife his efforts to
get out of the underworld lifestyle and
the respect he holds for his allies at
the Continental all unite at this moment
his severing of his own finger reminds
us that he is a man of focus commitment
and sheer will accepting disfigurement
certainly proves just how far he's
willing to go the scene in The Matrix in
which Neo Ducks backwards to avoid
gunfire is definitely iconic it's the
first image that immediately Springs to
mind when you say the phrase dodging
bullets as Neo and Trinity attempt to
rescue Morpheus they're ambushed by
agents on a rooftop agent Jones takes
over a nearby body and Begins the style
of weaving and bobbing around the
bullets that has become synonymous with
the Matrix franchise when Jones fires
back Neo bends over backwards to avoid
death with Reeves delivering arguably
the most famous moment of his career it
also represents a huge leap forward in
cinematic visual effects there are so
many reasons to grab the remote and
study this scene frame by frame over and
over again there's the sight of the
bullets flying across the screen over
Reeves's body the way his arms flail in
the air as he bends backwards and the
bullet barely grazing his leg this
moment also sets us on the path to
believe that Neo is indeed the chosen
one who will destroy the Matrix and free
the people once and for all in the force
awakens when kylo Ren froze Poe
dameron's laser with the force many fans
were triumphantly drawn back into the
world of Star Wars but that wasn't the
first time that a main character
showcased this ability in a major Sci-Fi
Action flick as Keanu Reeves fans are
well aware Neo had already performed
this same feat 12 years earlier in the
Matrix Reloaded before this
Unforgettable sequence happens Neo and
Company are headed to the Merovingian in
order to rescue the key maker who can
get them access to the source of the
Matrix after some hijinks involving the
merovingian's wife Neo manages to rescue
the key maker only for the marovingian
to then Corner him once some henchmen
opened fire on Neo he calmly puts his
hand up and brings the bullets to a
standstill thereby providing us with one
of the most unforgettable images in the
entire series of films this moment is
worth pausing not only because of Neo's
freezing ability but also because of how
effortlessly he does it when the
henchmen opened fire on him he puts one
hand out and brings the bullets to a
standstill all while maintaining the
same calm demeanor that he typically
wears within the Matrix his laid-back
attitude in the face of death has a huge
effect not just on the audience but also
the Merovingian upon witnessing this
display he remarks okay you have some
skin
the image of Neo preparing to face down
agent Smith one final time in The Matrix
Revolutions unquestionably belongs on
anybody's short list of Keanu Reeves's
most paused moments after finally making
it to the machine City Neo encounters
The Machine's leader deus ex machina
he's able to broker a deal in which he
stops agent Smith from taking over The
Matrix in the physical world while the
machine leader spares the free human
city of Zion the leader agrees and then
Neo is inserted into the Matrix to begin
his duel with agent Smith after Smith
goes on a monologue about how the
purpose of life is that it should end
Neo gets up and Strikes that famous pose
although this is hardly the first time
that Neo has taken this stance it rises
above all the others thanks to the sheer
Swagger that he displays despite the
long odds that he faces he chooses to
stand up when Smith knocks him down and
confidently beckons at him as if to say
come at me bro Neo's willpower
determination and refusal to stay down
are what make this moment profoundly
special
Keanu Reeves has starred in his fair
share of comedies but no scene in his
career has provided more laughs than the
one and always be my maybe when he comes
Waltzing into a high-class restaurant in
slow motion while awolnation's sale
plays in this scene Randall Parks Marcus
and Vivian bangs Jenny have gone to meet
Ali Wong's Sasha and her mystery
boyfriend at the restaurant after the
three get settled Sasha's boyfriend
arrives fashionably late and it's
dramatically revealed that she is in
fact dating Keanu Reeves who is of
course played by Reeves himself while
Reeves's screen time in this movie
amounts to a mere 14 minutes he makes
the most of it he takes all of the
hyperbole that's been said about him
over the years and pokes as much fun at
the audience as he does it himself as he
arrives in slow motion both Marcus and
Jenny's mouths fall wide open which
works as a parody of people who put
Reeves on a pedestal by having him play
into the assumptions that people have
about him he lures the audience into
laughing at themselves
1989's Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure was Reeve's first real
Blockbuster and the scene in which the
two title metal heads discover the
existence of time travel remains one of
the most memorable moments of his entire
career Reeves is Ted and Alex Winter's
Bill are working on a high school
history project that will determine
whether or not they pass their class and
although they don't know it yet it will
also decide whether their band will
become the basis for a future utopian
civilization while they sit outside a
Circle K Convenience Store working on
their assignment a strange man named
Rufus arrives from the future to ensure
that Bill and Ted succeed in their
mission his appearance is soon followed
by Bill and Ted from the future and then
hilarity ensues the look on tet's face
as he attempts to comprehend the strange
things unfurling in front of him is why
this sequence makes it onto our list his
exaggerated ignorance adds to the
farcical nature of this scene by playing
into many of the stereotypes about dumb
high schoolers including the number 69
only always being on their minds even
though this movie was released more than
30 years ago this scene has managed to
retain its most excellent entertainment
value by appealing to teenagers of
subsequent Generations who are still
alive and kicking oh and Ted give my
love to the princesses who
you'll see
few Keanu Reeve scenes are lingered upon
more than the one in speed in which he
hurls himself from a car onto a bus
while both vehicles are barreling along
at over 50 miles per hour Reeves plays
LAPD bomb defusal specialist Jack
travern who must deal with a man who's
threatening to blow up a Bus full of
people unless he's paid 3.7 million
dollars Jack and his partner Harry race
to catch up to the bus and stop the
extortionist before it's too late once
they catch this speeding vehicle Jack
makes the decision to join the bus
riders thus providing us with an
all-time classic action sequence Jack
jumping into a moving bus ranks among
Reeves's most paused Clips because of
the shock Factor as well as the bravado
that he displays the wow element and
Jack's fearlessness in a moment of
Crisis gets our hearts racing and set
the tone for what remains to come in one
of the best action movies of the 90s
Keanu Reeves taking a stroll through
hell in 2005's Constantine like it's no
big deal makes for a surreal and totally
pause worthy moment when a woman named
Isabel Dodson utters Constantine's name
before jumping off a tall building her
twin sister Angela goes to Constantine
to figure out why Isabelle killed
herself Constantine then decides that
the best course of action is for him to
transport himself to hell to find the
answers that Angela seeks the image of
Constantine walking among demons in Hell
makes for one of the coolest Keanu
Reeves moments because the
cinematography is simply amazing from
the howling winds blowing fire to the
general post-apocalyptic atmosphere the
setting alone makes for an incredible
moment then the demon zombies giving
Chase to Constantine as he tries to
recover a medical tag really hammer in
the gravity of the danger that he's in
it all combines for a moment that you'll
want to slow down just to soak
everything in
places
[Music]